can I show you something hell yeah
so I recorded this what is that song
never go she's my sweet little thing
[Music]
yeah he was an unbelievable sweet little
baby well if you covered that
yo that would be stupid bro I like to be
crazy yeah definitely let me see hold on
so I recorded this on my phone like as a
voice note and I sent it to my boy
Oliver and uh and he made this whole
beat around it now of course it's only
this small piece of it but I want to
show you it
cause like Stevie Ray Vaughan is the
reason why I sing like this
also that uh like I saw that movie The
Cadillac Records
and then after that I was already in the
jazz music and then I saw that and like
I just got even deeper into it so like a
lot of the way they sing too like money
Waters really The Howling Wolf uh what's
it called The Howling Wolf I need to see
it no the movie's called Cadillac
Records no yeah the movies called Kelly
rose
oh also I was I'll never go out and I
was at this bar with my kinfo CJ and
some rock song was playing I don't even
know what it was and I I've got that
Melody to it and I'm already a dog I'll
be out in public yeah so like yeah yeah
here we go
thank you
peace man he makes all those instruments
himself who's this Oliver
[Music]
[Applause]
oh yeah bro
[Music]
[Applause]
that was great
oh that is that's crazy
that's just unfinished right now that
sounds like a song comes about for you
like yo here be kind of yeah I didn't
even yeah like I said I was I was
singing to another song and then I just
I recorded that acapella and he made the
Beat Around it okay oh wow and you were
doing the just right now you're going to
is that is that that's how I'm gonna hit
it I just don't know what I'm gonna say
that's how I do a joke sometimes you're
a bad [__] no I mean that yeah I
know what the music of the joke is yeah
but sometimes I don't know like I know
what it needs to be to get them to move
in a way yeah but I don't know the words
that are there just yet I have the
premise of what I want to talk about but
that's so interesting because I always
describe it like music I was like yeah I
kind of know the rhythm of what it is
yeah so you're just
blowing on the beat
yeah
Chili Peppers like Nirvana like same
thing like that's why a lot of lyrics
don't make sense
[Music]
and they're like all right what goes
with that yeah and then they're just
finding words that fit in that they kind
of like that rhyme and and then they're
like yeah it doesn't matter what the
words are let's just make a cool a cool
track I mean this you could argue
not I don't want to say that the words
aren't the priority but especially with
music but like what we attach ourselves
to emotionally is the music and the
Rhythm and the sound right and then the
words on top will make you go this
delicious crazy right right because you
could rock out so just a beat I loved
your whole song when I thought it was
about Johnny Dan yeah and then I found
out
oh [__] I was like
[Music]
oh so interesting
yeah yeah oh I love that direction bro
so who helps curate that for you do you
have people who are like someone who's
as obsessed with music on the production
side as you are on the
what is it called the lyric side and the
singing side do you have another person
that you're partnering with to make
these things happen
what do you mean like lyrics was no no
like is Oliver your producer who's like
nah TV Robbie is my in-house producer
and then I got my buddy skills he'll
make some of my Beats uh I also work
with you know I work with the good beats
so like I you know like At first I used
to be like man nah I just want to work
with my people but I had to realize man
there's a whole world out there as
selfish as I want to be greatness needs
greatness bro and bring them with you
right of course you see what I'm saying
but I never want them to feel like I'm
leaving them because man I want us to
come together like you got to understand
I've built my [__] with them they need
game two though yeah like collabing with
these people ain't gonna take away you
know food off their plate they're just
gonna learn what this level of beat
making is what I'm saying yeah so so
yeah now I'm doing that working with
other people I met all of uh uh over
there at Johnny swipe [__] at cinematic
but I I [__] with olive oil I ended up
punching in with them he made the cowboy
killer beat I mean that one was that one
was funky he made Brandon yeah Brianna
was cool too yeah
I was [__] and throwing up on myself
at the same time when I made that song I
ate bad salmon and then I was I was like
I was bro it was bad man and uh I'm
throwing up on myself and I get a call
and it's Johnny he's like hey I need you
he was like how you doing I said I'm
chilling what's up you know cause like I
don't I don't you know I already
I don't need to talk to him about it and
uh he was like all right well I need you
in college tomorrow I was like I just
hung up [__] that I ain't trying to hear
none of that you know I [__] they got
so bad I just laid in the shower and
leaked
and then uh you know I got the [__]
California I'm sitting here like biting
Ginger straight off the [__] just
trying to do anything to get my ability
to feel better and I'll [__] um
when and now [__] came out and I [__]
I knocked out like eight songs that
night what was the one song in the album
where like you have some sort of
distortion on The Voice
or where it gets lower yeah I was
chopped oh OMG OMG yeah yeah what were
you putting on that it's just load it's
just slowed down interesting yeah
because at first I was like is someone
featured on this like so I'm really
hitting it faster it just slowed down so
you hit it faster I hit it at your
normal pace which is probably like 145
160 BPM and it's loaded down to whatever
it is at now it was cool yeah I got a
few songs like that it's called it's
called screwed or slowed that's the yeah
chopping screw yeah but I don't chop it
though I just screw it what does chop
mean like where it plays it back
like if I'm like kick those click to the
day that don't kick don't kick those
click to the kick though
right and chopping is when you're gonna
yeah there's some songs that are not
screwed it's just chopped
um
I like that you don't put yourself in a
box like you're rapping but then you
also have country songs well you gotta
understand this rap [__] at this point
it's like like How Better Could I get
right so now I'm just having fun but
also I think the song Barrio I really
like that [__] actually it's fine that
[__] was funny right yeah like cowboy
and that's why I've been enjoying those
songs a lot more because they're just
fun you know what I'm saying like this
rap [__] like I said it's fun and [__]
but it's not that it's old it's like I'm
just unlocking new characters every day
that's the thing is like most people are
starting rap in their teens
you've been doing it for 20 years in
your 24. yeah right yeah so I do
understand that there's some probably
monotony with it what is that just like
uh repetitiveness oh yeah
yeah I mean that's my favorite lyric
because I don't even know how to how to
rap I just rhyme words yeah like I don't
even rap but it's wrong I got another
song where I say 80 degrees
yeah yeah yeah
I got another song where I say I could
say stupid [__] and it still sound good
see stupid [__]